this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by curiosity stream watch
thousands of documentaries for free for
31 days a curiosity stream calm Ford /
real engineering at the outbreak of the
Second World War the United States was
lagging behind many of the other nations
in the industry of tank development and
manufacture and their British allies
were not much better equipped in the
field of armoured warfare following the
speedy fall of France in 1940 at the
hands of the aggressive German advance
they knew they needed to upgrade and
develop their weapons and armoured
vehicles making a new tank model to
compete with the very capable German
tanks would require it to be agile well
armored with rock-solid reliability have
a powerful gun that could take out
enemies from all angles and perhaps most
importantly to be quick and cheap to
manufacture however combining all these
traits into one tank is no easy task and
in July of 1940 a new medium tank the m3
was proposed intended to be a stopgap
solution the War Department confirmed
and authorized its development quickly
and just a year later the first models
were rolling off the production line and
shipped to the frontlines the United
States wanted a 75 millimeter gun in the
turret however their engineering
capabilities were nowhere near advanced
enough to realize this goal in such a
short turn over time fitting a large gun
like this presents numerous design
challenges chief among these was
building a whole capable of supporting
it at this stage the u.s. did not have
the equipment needed to build a large
turf ring and the technology needed to
cast a whole strong enough to bear a
large Taurus and thus the EM tree Li was
produced as an interim model while the
design of a larger fully traversable
turret fitted with a 75 millimeter gun
was figured out and the molds for a cast
whole were developed the m3 only ever
managed to bear a sponson mounted 75
millimeter gun and the turret was
instead fitted with a weaker 37
millimeter gun with a hole consisting of
simple flat panels riveted together
this gave the 75 millimeter gun the
space it needed inside the hole which
was
not available in the small Taurus these
design trade-offs disadvantaged the
entry greatly if the crew wanted to fire
the main gun over a sand or earth bank
they would be forced to fully expose the
whole of the tank and the entire tank
would have to turn to aim the main gun
making the main gun clumsy and slow to
control the Americans were well aware of
these design issues and were busy
designing the EM trees replacement even
before the m3 entered production this
replacement would eventually become
known as the m4 Sherman the most
produced allied tank of world war ii and
the workhorse of the front line while
the m3 was never intended to be a
long-term solution it did influence many
of the design decisions for the m4
Sherman the m4 and m3 shared the same
vertical volume suspension system which
used coiled sheep spring steel this
structure allows the coils to slide past
each other opposed to typical helical
Springs which hit a limit in compression
when the coils contact each other
allowing the sheet metal spring to
tolerate heavier loads in a more compact
space while being easy to maintain and
replace the lessons learned from the
past year of the war thought the
Ordnance Department that the new tank
would have to be both fast and easy to
produce taking lessons from the American
automotive mass manufacturing industry
Chrysler Ford and General Motors all
contributed to its manufacture the
engineers of the Sherman wanted all
parts to be standardized so each unit
could be simply and hastily assembled
these parts would also need to be simple
to remove so the m4 could be repaired in
a combat situation with minimal delays
the bogies which were sets of rubber
road wheels that transfer the weight of
the tank to the track were bolted to the
hull so that they could be removed with
ease for repair the m4 finally fulfilled
the Americans desire for a 360-degree
fully traversable 75 millimeter gun the
turret itself was made from a single
cast part
rounded to deflect incoming rounds and
bolted to the turret ring they fitted
the turret with a single axis gyro to
stabilize the gun allowing it to fire
with greater
accuracy while in motion but with the
relatively low muzzle velocity of 610
m/s it diminished the effectiveness of
the turret and would be the basis of
most problems the m4 faced in the later
years of the war the main weapon was
however complemented by a 50 caliber
machine gun mounted on top of the turret
with a coaxial 30 caliber machine gun
and another 30 caliber gun operated by
the bow gunner making it a formidable
infantry support tank production was
simple and in full swing by 1942 at the
height of production one m4 Sherman
rolled off the assembly line every 30
minutes just as America revolutionized
mass manufacturing with the Ford Model T
which I have covered in more detail in
the past America was now revolutionising
the production of armored vehicles and
thanks to the land lease agreement
signed in early 1941 America was allowed
to export thousands of tanks to Britain
and the Soviet Union most estimates of
wartime production reached over 50,000
units but the Sherman wasn't produced in
just one model each new variant built
upon those before us most focusing on
improving the engine and the method of
construction for the whole for example
early m4 hull designs like the m4a1 were
constructed from a cast hole where the
entire hull was cast in a single block
this was a difficult process and
required a lot of specialized workers
and equipment and was difficult to
repair in the field
it was soon dropped in favour of a
simpler welded design where the hole was
constructed from multiple flat and
casted parts welded together these welds
were weak point in the hull and these
two were gradually minimized with
additional armor plating and superior
construction to reduce the number of
welds needed one of the largest problems
that resulted in a major redesign was
the floatation problem where the weight
of the tank was not being spread over a
wide enough area this increases the
pressure the tank will exert on the
ground and thus make it sink further
into the ground increasing both the
power needed to move and slowing it down
or worse still getting stuck
completely to deal with this problem
some Sherman's were fitted with track
and connectors called grousers to
increase the track width and thus
decreased the ground pressure a more
significant design change was brought in
in 1944 with the introduction of a
horizontal volute spring suspension this
as the name suggests moved the springs
from a vertical to horizontal position
which reduced their height and allowed
for the addition of a hydraulic shock
absorber to smoothen the ride and
reducing the stress on the springs which
had a notoriously short life the road
wheels were now placed in parallel Paris
which allowed the track to increase in
width to 0.58 of a meter a massive
increase in track width that drastically
decreased the tank's ground pressure and
thus increased its mobility other
changes were made to improve the
survivability of the m4 as a result of
horrific lessons learned on the
battlefield the Sherman initially had 57
degree frontal armor forcing the
designers to implement tiny driver and
bow gunner hatches these hatches were
far too small and made evacuation
procedures difficult made even worse by
the fact that a large amount of
ammunition was stored in the vulnerable
torus which often cooked off when the
tank was hit resulting in horrific fires
in late 1943 changes were made to
improve the crews chances of surviving
after a critical hit the armor angle was
reduced to 47 degrees providing more
space to incorporate larger hatches the
majority of ammunition was also moved to
the floor of the tank where it was
better armored and less likely to catch
fire they also implemented wet storage
where each shell was separated by
canisters filled with a gel-like
substance made of water antifreeze and a
rust inhibitor if the Amarok was hit
these containers would be pierced
releasing the gel which would cool and
quench the rounds at this stage the
Sherman was a formidable foe for any
Panzer tank however as the war
progressed newer and stronger German
Panther and Tiger tanks entered the fray
to increase the m4s chances against
these advanced German tanks a final
major redesign was introduced with the
inclusion of a more powerful 70
six millimeter gun bringing us to
perhaps the best m4 variant that fought
in World War two the m4a3e8 or the easy
ace which incorporated every improvement
I've mentioned in this video making it a
formidable opponent for any German tank
this was just one of many Sherman
variants that entered the fray with
specialized weapons some were fitted
with rocket tubes which were rotated
with the turret and fired in a barrage
at soft targets others were fitted with
flamethrowers while some took on roles
as frontline workhorses being fitted
with bulldozer blades and hedgerow
clearing tools to clear a path for other
vehicles and infantry others were
modified with flails to clear minefields
designated as the sherman crap this was
a tremendous size during d-day
operations with the chain swinging
wildly round striking the ground with a
sickening sound for an eon lucas
occasionally the chains would break off
after successfully detonating a mind
forcing any nearby infantry to duck for
cover 290 Sherman's were modified for
the amphibious assault of Normandy
called the DD tank these Sherman's were
fitted with rear mounted propellers
which diverted power from the trucks
using a bevel gear which was the origin
of the DD suffix
standing for duplex Drive they were also
fitted with a folding canvas screen to
increase the buoyancy of the tank and
allow it to wade into shore despite
showing itself to be an incredibly
capable machine the Sherman has a bad
reputation in some circles but the old
myth that our took five Sherman's to
defeat one tiger as perpetuated by the
movie fury it shouldn't be a surprise
that a medium tank like a Sherman would
be at a disadvantage to a defending
heavy tank but this statistic is simply
untrue the Allies were also at a huge
disadvantage with getting larger and
heavier tanks into mainland Europe where
Germany could easily transport these
vehicles Overland immediately out of the
factory these World War 2 logistics are
one of the most fascinating subjects
I've ever encountered and so I have
decided to create an entire series
dedicated to exploring the largest
and planning that went into d-day and
other battles of World War two starting
with the first episode exploring how and
why the Allies chose Normandy as a
landing location that series will be
made with the support of curiosity
stream a subscription streaming service
with thousands of documentaries and
nonfiction titles and will debut next
month on nebula a streaming video
platform built by and for independent
creators like tears ooh Lindsay Alice
minutephysics Wendover productions and
loads more where curiosity stream is all
about big-budget
non-fiction videos we're building nebula
because we want a place for educational
creators to try out new content ideas
that might not work on YouTube
especially stuff that might get
demonetised like a war related series
curiosity stream loves independent
creators and wants to help us grow our
platform so they're offering real
engineering viewers free access to
nebula when you sign up to curiosity
stream comm Ford slash real engineering
by signing up for curiosity stream
you'll get access to thousands of
documentaries like this one called plain
resurrection that details the
restoration of World War 2 era planes
and you'll get access to the first
episode of my new channel real science
we already have some fantastic original
series on the platform like grand test
auto a carrier view show from my friends
JT from second thought and Joseph from
real-life lore by signing up to
curiosity stream you will be helping not
just me but the entire educational
community as we work together to build a
place where we can create content like
my logistics of d-day series that would
just be too risky to rely on YouTube as
always thanks for watching and thank you
to all my patreon supporters if you'd
like to see more from me the links to my
Instagram Twitter subreddit and discord
server are below
you